if you wanted to argue with me that you
wanted to do this behavior or act in a
certain way
and what you were saying was hey Jocko
you're kind of a pussy because you don't
want to do this or you're not going to
allow this or you don't want us to do to
act in that in that way my trump card
was real simple and real straightforward
and it won a hundred percent of the time
it was the ace of spades
you'd rather go out and get drunk they'd
go and fight al-qaeda if that's where
you're at fuck you I don't want you on
my team I'd only want to be associated
with you if any of you do anything that
prevents us from going to war I will
never forgive you and I will hate you
forever there's a group of human beings
on this planet that want to destroy our
way of life and I have the opportunity
to go and hunt them down you're gonna
take that away or you're gonna put that
in any kind of risk not happening